l'inégal répartition des ressources en
eau entre les codes de la réunion
l'oriental pluvieuse et l'occidental
sèche a amené le conseil général a
initié en 1983 le projet d'irrigation du
littoral ouest
ce projet s'inscrit dans le cadre de la
mise en place d'une politique de gestion
globale de l'eau pour répondre aux
enjeux en termes de développement liés à
son utilisation dans une région à fort
potentiel économique agricole et
industriel la solution retenue permet de
transférer d'est en ouest par 30
kilomètres de galeries souterraines les
eaux captées dans les cirques de mafate
et de salazie
ce chantier d'envergure mise en oeuvre à
partir de 1989 à utiliser du matériel et
des équipements de haute technologie
accompagné de mesures environnementales
pour aménager des dispositifs grandiose
il a duré jusqu'en 2012 le coût du
projet îlot s'élève à 925 millions
d'euros dont 432 millions de fonds
européens et 76 millions de fonds d'état
cette précieuse ressource hydraulique
est d'ores et déjà distribués aux
agriculteurs et aux cinq communes de la
côte ouest de la possession jusqu'à
saint leu
outre les galeries souterraines le
projet d'irrigation du littoral ouest se
compose de quatre ouvrages de captage
d'un réservoir de 50 mille mètres cubes
de 42 km de conduites principales
gravitaire de huit antennes de
distribution en refoulement composé de
46 km de réseau de 40 réservoir de 3000
à 2000 mètres cubes et de 35 stations de
pompage
depuis 2002 100 % du linéaire de la
galerie et excavés 70% du périmètre est
équipé 760 exploitations agricoles sont
abonnés et 5000 hectares sont équipés
quatre communes bénéficient déjà de
cette précieuse ressource 12 millions de
mètres cubes sont distribués par an et 3
millions de mètres cubes sont restitués
dans la rivière des galets avec le
développement de la diversification
cultural la production de canne à sucre
dans l'ouest et multiplier par cinq la
livraison totale du projet est prévue en
les travaux de l'antenne 2 du périmètre
d'irrigation prioritaires sont destinés
à l'irrigation d'environ 605 hectares
jusqu'aux eaux du ruisseau situé à 600 m
sur la commune de saint paul celle ci
s'effectue à partir de l'eau transportée
par la conduite maîtresse première
tranche
ces travaux d'une durée de 25 mois pour
un coût de 17 millions d'euros comporte
la conduite d'adduction et refoulement
en acier d'un diamètre variant de 350 à
500 millimètres sur une longueur totale
de 3800 mètres pour permettre la
réalisation du réseau secondaire dans
des conditions de sécurité
satisfaisantes du fait des contraintes
topographiques lié à une pente de plus
de 75%
le bardage des tuyaux a nécessité
l'emploi de moyens héliportés
la mise en oeuvre de la conduite
principale a nécessité la création d'une
piste d'une largeur de 18 mètres pour
permettre le bardage des tubes le
stockage des déblais et des matériaux de
remblais
afin de faire transiter l'eau depuis la
conduite maîtresse jusqu'à la côte 660 m
quatre réservoirs et quatre stations de
pompage ont nécessité quinze mille
tonnes de sable et gravier 6500 mètres
cubes de béton 380 tonnes d'armatures
onze mille mètres carrés de coffrage
dont 2000 m² circulaire le ferrasse man
représente quant à lui 29 mille mètres
cubes de déblais et 20 mille mètres
cubes de remblais et les réseaux
tertiaires ou réseaux de distribution
des parcelles limité à seize bornes dans
le cadre des travaux
ce sont des canalisations en fonte d'un
diamètre variant entre 100 et 250 mm sur
5900 mètres
l'ensemble des travaux s'est effectuée
en collaboration avec les bureaux
d'études environnementales
missionné dans le cadre de l'opération
afin de minimiser l'impact sur la flore
et faune environnante par ailleurs des
aménagements spécifiques en dû être mise
en oeuvre du fait de la présence de la
zone de surveillance renforcée des
forages d'eau potable à proximité de la
zone de travaux l'ensemble de ces
équipements apporte une capacité de
stockage supplémentaire à 9000 mètres
cubes et permettent de refouler débit
variant de 720 à 1400 mètres cubes par
heure en fonction des besoins exprimés
par les exploitations agricoles
au final 67 agriculteurs bénéficieront
de l'antenne 2 pour une surface de 400
31 hectares